غادر قائد مجموعه فاغنرا الترابا الروسيه
نحو بيلاروسيا وغادرت قواته مقاطعه روستوف
انتهت الازمه في ظاهرها فماذا بعد تسيطر
الاسئله الان بشان مصير مجموعه فاجنر
برمتها كشفت احداث السبت عما يعتقد انها
تصدعات في اهم اركان قوه بوتين وهو الهيكل
الامني والعسكري وتذهب التحليلات لقراءه
التطورات المحتمله من خلال صفقه الكريملين
مع بريجوجين بواسطه بيلاروسيا
فقد تضمنت عوده مقاتلي فاجنر الذي نقتربوا
من موسكو الى معسكراتهم مقابل اغلاق
القضيه الجنائيه بالتحريض على التمرد
المسلح بحق بريكوجين ومغادرته الى
بيلاروسيا وان لا يخضع اي من مقاتلي فاجنر
ممن شاركوا في الهجوم الاخير لاي ملاحقه
قانونيه بعد تسريحهم اما المقاتلون الذين
لم يشاركوا في حمله بريجوجين فيمكنهم
توقيع عقود مع وزاره الدفاع للانضمام الى
القوات المسلحه
لا ينتهي كل شيء بتنفيذ ما ورد في هذه
الصفقه
اذ ما الذي يضمن عدم حدوث اضطرابات كهذه
مستقبلا كما توقع وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
انطوني بلينكن فقد ابدى استغرابه لعدم
حدوث اقالات لقاده عسكريين في روسيا لقد
اثار مشهد عبور ارتال من فاجنر من مقاطعه
روستوف جنوبا الى تخوم موسكو دون اعتراض
اي من القوات الامنيه او العسكريه اثار
علامات استفهام والتدابير الاستثنائيه
التي اتخذتها السلطات في موسكو تثير
تساؤلات عن من يحمي العاصمه والكرملين
ومراكز القرار لقد كشفت تحرك فاجنر عن
شكوك في تماسك الجبهه الداخليه الروسيه
وباتت جبهات الحرب في اوكرانيا امام تحد
كبير ليس الامر مقتصرا على هذا فهناك
جبهات اخرى تنتشر فيها قوات فاجنر لتكون
اليد طول لروسيا في القاره الافريقيه ينشط
اكثر من خمسه عشر الف مقاتل تابعين
للمجموعه في دول افريقيه ابرزها افريقيا
الوسطى والسودان وليبيا وبوركينا فاسو
ومالي
فما مصير هذه القوات ومن سيديرها وهل
ستفكك موسكو ما توصف بذراعها الطوله ام
انها ستعيد هيكلتها بقياده جديده